When we think about climate
change and pollution,
we usually think about oil-soaked birds,
fossil gas platforms in the Arctic
or black smoke rising above coal plants.
We never think about banks,
insurers and investors.
But we should.
Because money is a driving force
beyond fossil fuel extraction
and environmental destruction.
The most polluting sector
on the planet is not fossil fuels.
It's finance.
Sure, you've heard banks are increasingly
putting money into green projects,
and yes, they are financing
green projects,
but they are doing it
on top of new polluting oil,
coal and gas projects.
I have been looking
at the math for a decade,
and it's still a green droplet
in the ocean of pollution.
I started to campaign
to protect the environment
and human rights
when I was at university,
and I cannot count how many times
I've heard financiers telling me,
"Sorry, we need coal."
Sometimes they said,
"We can make it clean."
Mostly I've heard,
"It's impossible.
There is nothing we can do."
Rather than be discouraged,
that gave me the strength
to prove them wrong.
But how does someone like me,
with a small group of partners,
take on the big banks and insurers?
Well, we start by making smart demands.
Then we incentivize action.
And finally, we add
a spoonful of blackmail
that I like to think of
as a friendly nudge.
(Laughter)
When we set out to solve
the issues of the world,
we might want too much at once.
The end of poverty,
a peaceful world,
a healthy planet.
But how do you climb
an unscalable mountain
one step after another?
The most important thing
is to identify the SMART demand.
Smart as in S.M.A.R.T.
Something that is specific,
measurable, achievable,
relevant and time-bound.
Something that you can
realistically achieve
based on the resources you have,
your target and the balance of power
between you and your target.
You don't want something that requires
more than 12 to 18 months to achieve
because you will lose momentum.
Victory sells, defeat does not.
However, you don't want your objective
to be too easy, either,
because if it's too easy,
it's not likely to change anything
in the way the system works.
And we want the system to change.
So you want your objective
to be disruptive and transformative
to bring you closer to your final goal.
For the past 10 years,
my goal has always been
the end of all financing
of all fossil fuels.
But back in 2013,
even the idea that banks
could automatically reject
a whole sector of the economy
appeared as crazy
and was not open for discussion.
So at that time, a smart objective
was to convince one bank
to withdraw from one project.
And it didn’t take me long to come across
one of the most insane projects:
a huge coal mine that could open the way
to eight other coal projects
and destroy the Great Barrier Reef,
a UNESCO site.
This was Alpha Coal mine in Australia,
supported by French bank Societe Generale.
Our first SMART objective
was to get this bank out of this project,
and we succeeded after a year
of relentless campaigning.
Today --
(Applause)
Today, the coal of the Alpha Coal mine
is still in the ground.
And from there, we moved on
to our second objective.
To get French banks to commit
not to finance any of the projects
located in the same basin
of the Alpha Coal mine.
We succeeded,
moved on to our third objective,
to get French banks to commit
not to finance any new coal mines,
any new coal plants worldwide.
We did one bank, two banks,
three banks, four banks,
until we convinced all French banks,
the fourth-biggest
banking sector worldwide,
to reject all project financing
for the coal sector.
(Applause)
And from there, we carry on
until reaching our final goal:
to get French financial institutions,
not only the banks but also the insurers,
investors, AXA and Amundi,
to exit from the coal sector entirely.
Not just say "no" to projects,
but also to companies
with existing coal operations.
This goal seemed completely
impossible a few years ago,
and yet it's currently happening.
Today, six trillion dollars of assets
managed by French financial institutions
are covered by a coal exit policy.
It helps if we think from the position
of the person we try to convince.
It will make my life a lot easier
if my job was to convince every banker
of the moral necessity
to stop financing fossil fuels.
But that's not my job.
My job is to make sure they stop
no matter the reasons.
As campaigners,
our first responsibility is to think
who needs to be convinced,
what kind of arguments
are they likely to listen to the most.
Bankers, insurers,
these people don't live in a bubble.
They have seen the fires and the floods
of the past months,
and as many of us,
most of them are getting worried
for themselves and for their kids.
But the world is driven by digits,
ruled by a system that demands profits.
So when I meet with the head of investment
of a big financial institution,
I don't bang on the table and say,
"Our planet is on fire," which it is.
I say, "Have you thought
about your long term risk profile?
The project that your client is developing
might be forced to close down
because of a new climate regulation
or because a green alternative
has become cheaper.
Not only you might not profit from it,
but you might actually lose money."
Bankers and financial institutions
are slowly realizing
that this climate issue
is something they need to care about.
If they don't deal with it,
climate change will deal with them.
(Applause)
Yet even the argument
of the financial risk
doesn't always hit the mark.
But there is one argument
which is stronger than any other:
the reputational risk.
Financial institutions spend
millions and millions
to appear as green as possible,
and they would not want
that good PR money to go to waste.
A good reputation takes years to build,
but it can be lost in a week.
And we can use that to our advantage.
If you don't do the right thing
and have your dirty financing revealed,
you might lose clients,
current employees, new talents.
Where will your next generation
of employees come from
if people feel embarrassed
to come work for you?
Once I wrote a report about a big
French bank's hypocrisy on climate.
This bank had stopped financing coal mines
and claimed it was for climate reasons.
But the same bank was actively supporting
the building of new coal plants.
What a hypocritical stand, right?
So I wrote the report,
but I didn't publish it straight away.
Instead, I sent it to the bank
and gave them two options.
Either I can throw the report away,
or I could send it to the press,
depending on the bank's decision
to meet my demands
after a specific deadline
and stop financing coal plants
on top of new coal mines.
(Laughter and applause)
It's not a ransom, not a trap.
Just a friendly nudge.
I'm only here to help.
As long as the bank is ready to consider
my demands and give it a try.
(Laughter and applause)
We help by providing information and data,
sometimes better
than private data providers.
And we are not just here
to mourn and criticize.
When things are headed
in the right direction,
we are all supportive.
And when finally, financial
institutions publicly commit
to withdraw from a polluting sector,
we celebrate.
In less than 10 years,
25 global financial institutions
are phasing out coal financing for good.
In 2017, AXA was the first insurer
to stop insuring new coal projects
and stop investing in companies
that developed new coal plants.
In 2019, Crédit Agricole
became the first global bank
to adopt a comprehensive coal exit policy.
Step by step,
we are climbing this unscalable mountain,
and it's working.
Today, coal companies
are struggling to secure the financing
and the coverage needed
for their operations.
Today, the small group of people
has become a much bigger crowd,
and these people are taking on
European, American and Asian
financial institutions.
It's no longer only about coal,
but also about oil and gas.
To decarbonize finance,
to solve the climate issues
is not just about voting with your wallet
and moving your money to an ethical bank.
It's about joining these people
and marching through the front doors
of big banks and insurers
to demand the impossible.
Thank you.
(Applause)